we are with a man of the hour here in
Saint Louis Darius Verge after an
amazing Victory against Levon aronian
Darius first of all congratulations how
do you feel after uh taking down such a
strong opponent tired
happy and tired
yeah how was the game from your
perspective it felt like he was trying
to take you out of the opening early on
it's very complicated honestly don't
know what was going on for the majority
of the game
I mean I don't know honestly like I know
that I was worse out of the opening
that's for sure and then I guess he got
to over to ambition at some point and I
took over and then my technique was
probably I'm for sure was not the best
but I guess it was sufficient and he
played this move H3 uh yeah actually
yeah this was I mean
yeah like this move I mean it seems like
it's just harmless but in reality it's
not easy to react because like normal
normally that wants to play with E5 but
the NC text D5 cxd5 net B5 is of course
an issue like typically between this
position that's why he played Rook C1
earlier to have Knights uh yeah and
Bishop B8 uh there is not only we should
be free but it's also Queen c29 C7 ideas
I'm not sure whether you should
including episode crooked or or not
um but in either case I think it's
dangerous for me because my sister is
coming yeah and e494 always so it just
makes no sense so I think he's doing
very well here and honestly I want to
play with B6 I really want to play with
B6 here but CTX D5 again was a problem
for me if C tax d59 B5 again is a
problem and a similar ideas pretty much
so if it takes deep 95 I don't want to
play of course but it takes D5
the Knight D4 are for the problem and I
calculate some weird weird lines like C5
neither five for instance and let's say
Bishop B8 let's say or something just
for instance and I'm thinking Knight
takes D5 works that takes effect Queen
G4 other than miscalculated something
but I guess it wins let's see maybe
three yes yes that's Checkmate in three
yes that's what I thought that's what I
saw okay this definitely works yeah
that's why I mean I I don't have to play
Bishop B8 and I don't have to take on D5
even but all right uh Bishop E5 was a
move but I thought I'm worse here yeah
if I just for the morals here before
yeah I just looked towards to me so for
this reason here I mean I just sort of
you know I didn't know what to do sir I
couldn't understand what my plan should
be if I can play E5 I can play B6 what
am I supposed to attack on C4 and pop
idea that was that if he takes bxc4 I
play E5 and then I get my knight to C5
Rook EA maybe Queen E7 which comes to F5
um I think normal it's a normal
interesting position so you're not
actually worried I wasn't with his job I
was not about to worry about G4 now got
it but he played Bishop X4 was just
correct uh B5 now we got some meron like
structure and he plays H4 which is good
I think uh H6 and Knight G5 is probably
too ambitious because C5 I think solves
about my problems I think
um and I think you're right in your
assessment as well yeah here we have to
take the Knight I thought on only four
and two positions just around equal at
five yeah I was one I want to play five
I wasn't sure Queen G3 uh it's E5 Knight
C3 and it was a disposition but I
thought I should be good here yep
um yeah okay engine confirm the engine
confirms yeah C4 B4 maybe you want some
Queen B6 ideas yeah I mean I wasn't sure
about before because we can do the live
scores but okay sound position here I
also like okay I take the pawn queen hd5
and for sure I'm not worth here uh uh
yeah as far as it was sort in a way you
know sort of expecting Rook H3 G3 I
don't know if he if I I don't know I
thought at least I can I can repeat but
I don't know if I can play Queen G6
which actually it's possible okay I
thought I could do that too but I wasn't
sure I thought like at least I have a
drug yeah so uh yeah and then I would
think of course but uh yeah hero was
getting very sharp very very sharp and
he wins upon but uh his King is very
weak and groups force in the blunder all
right yeah
um
yeah I mean it looks scary for him for
sure like the United four is coming yeah
for the big threat Queen H1 always I can
throw in any moment it's some some idea
rukong G3 is actually all very awkward
so yeah it's just like Queen to C4 might
be four of the ways but even after
Knight to F4 it looks very scary
yeah this is not easy it's really Queen
takes a queen takes the four yeah
okay it's very very difficult very
difficult and if you play this move Rook
to C4 which is a blunder yeah I mean I
didn't really know it's a blunder I just
thought Queen H1 looks very strong yeah
yeah
and yeah here Queen A3 here I was like
okay must be winning either four yeah uh
this queen D3 and I'm sure Queen D5 was
the best move uh
uh yeah Queen if I was about 25. I was
thinking of Queen D2 maybe I should
could throw in or something but
um okay still better but that's what I
thought it was King because I wanted to
have this have him just have him have
this Pawn on e4 that way uh he cannot
really do like moves like Queen A7 let's
say because we defeat me always that's
why I play Move Queen D5 E4 Queen takes
D2 right now yeah this is this is that's
why I play Queen D5 yeah
um yeah very honestly yeah and now F5 I
mean this must be obviously totally
winning and my technique was terrible uh
yeah it'll be seven
stupid move yeah okay this must be
winning but
still not okay here yeah I mean here
basically has lots of practical chances
yeah and uh
I mean I will I will start try to
calculate but then I just decided to
sort of trust my God and just take on it
to take these pawns and let's see it was
faster but I thought that you're getting
concerned of course I was getting
concerned that's why I burned so much
time here was after time control and I
wasn't sure like I knew that I should
never lose this of course but whether
it's winning and how easily is this
winning
you know it's it's very difficult to
tell what was the next toughest moment I
guess for you in your calculation
because yeah I mean the assessment
stayed pretty much good for you
throughout the year yeah I mean it's
more like seeing ghosts in here so I
just wasn't sure what I'm calculating
like uh
yeah I mean of course if engine is
easily winning but the board is like
this looks scary simply it doesn't look
scary but a lot of ghosts with this Pawn
C6 and D5 and you know the margin of
blunder of a blunder is very very small
so I was I was concerned about it but
yeah I guess it wins C7 Rook C8 T6 the
attack on G2 and here Rook F1 okay
Bishop D4 H5 is the best move yes okay
H5 is definitely the best and then H4
and then Rook to F5 and I think maybe
King G6 but it's still I just saw that
uh
uh just to interrupt you for a second
this one did finish in a draw
Alice seems to have been better but she
couldn't complete the win never mind no
the game still goes that is not a draw
no they have to make an extra repetition
they were got it yeah yeah
now it's a draw
let's keep going with the analysis yeah
yeah so I play King G6 because I felt
like if I bring my king to the to this
pawns and I always the thing is I
actually can't move back a few moves of
King C2 I thought King D2 is the only
try correct yes it's of Kings to King D2
in order to play D7 but then I play Rook
F7 yes this was the key Point yes uh and
that's why I play H5 because even though
I lose the G2 on my Pokemon H4 response
are blocked and it must be winning of
course yeah I mean it's just too much
right and then you lose the C7 Pawn Yeah
that's why I played H4 you know to not I
will lose probably one of these pawns on
G2 or G3 but not both of them that's why
page for very nicely calculated Darius
congratulations uh a big win for you
guys any questions not at all uh there's
I know how it feels like you want to
beat yourself like you could have won it
earlier or something like that but uh
think of how much excitement
you gave us
the adrenaline something the time
trouble it was wonderful and uh yeah
thank you yeah I mean I'm definitely
happy of course because
um it was a tough game and I'm tired yes
go and enjoy well-deserved rest and uh
well we have all results but again